ich habe einen Nachtzug in Norwegen mit
eigenem Schlafabteil getestet und so
viel habe ich bezahlt um von der
norwegischen Hauptstadt Oslo nach
stavanga zu kommen bin ich in den F5
sortoget Nachtzug gestiegen dieser fährt
abends um kurz vor 11 Uhr in Oslo ab und
kommt dann früh am nächsten Morgen ins
davanga an um in seine Schlafkabine zu
gelangen muss man erstmal in die
Rezeption vom Zug um die Karte abzuholen
mit der man in sein Zimmer kommt also
eigentlich wie im Hotel so sah das
Abteil dann aus ich muss sagen ja das
sehr gut gefallen Komfort war auf jeden
Fall gegeben und für eine Nachtzug echt
bequem ein Waschbecken war auch dabei
Dusche und Toilette allerdings nicht ich
habe mir danach zum eins noch was zu
Essen gekauft das Essen ist Angebot weiß
aber nicht so vielfältig und bezahlt
habe ich am Ende 135 € 30 also meiner
Meinung nach vorne in Ordnung